[Music]
held in a hotel and facing deportation
the world's number one tennis player is
waiting for a final decision from an
australian judge on whether his covert
vaccination exemption is valid without
the permission he will not be able to
defend his 2021 title this year
and he's not alone
renata vorakova of the czech republic
who already played a warm-up tournament
in melbourne has had her australian visa
cancelled and is being detained in the
same hotel as the serbian sportsman
novak djokovic was held for about eight
hours by border officials who cancelled
his visa and refused him entry
they said he failed to provide enough
evidence to meet australia's entry
requirements
while the tennis star's mother suggested
his treatment was inhumane an australian
minister insisted the player is not
being held captive mr jokovic is not
being killed held captive in australia
he is free to leave at any time that he
chooses to do so and water force will
actually facilitate
that
his supporters and family members
demonstrated in the streets of belgrade
and his wife shared an instagram post
expressing gratitude to the supporters
it's christmas today for us my wishes
are for everyone to be healthy happy
safe and together with families
we wish we were all together today but
my consolation is that at least we are
healthy and we will grow from this
experience
thank you dear people all around the
world for using your voice to send love
to my husband
the only law that we should all respect
across every single border is love and
respect for another human being
love and forgiveness is never a mistake
but a powerful force
this detention hotel is a long way from
the five-star accommodation that
djokovic is used to but on the streets
his supporters are hoping that the nine
times australian open champion will beat
the system that says it gives him no
special treatment and defend his title
on the court
until then he's stuck between these four
walls unsure if he'll be playing the
australian open or flying home
nicole johnston
sky news in melbourne